ahsokatano who left the Jedi Order
before helping to establish a network of
various Rebel cells against the Galactic
Empire cestus a Jedi Knight who lived in
seclusion on the planet braa for years
SE junda who was eventually captured and
severely tortured by the Empire before
becoming a mentor to cestus Eno Cordova
a Jedi scholar and archaeologist with a
deep interest in the ancient
civilizations of the Galaxy grou a
member of the same species as Yoda who
was rescued by the Jedi Keller and Beck
Kan and jerus also known as Caleb Doom
who forsook the Jedi ways for some time
before joining her ula's Rebel cell
knock meded who left the order to pursue
his own path even before the beginning
of the Clone Wars and eventually had a
daughter named jhara APO ran cissus who
is known to be one of the wisest members
of the Jedi Council quinland Vos who was
a Maverick within the Jedi Order and was
renowned for his retrocognition uel a
Jedi master who entrusted Antron Bach
with a Starship loaded with all the Jedi
artifacts he had managed to collect
before Order 66 Yoda the Grand Master of
the Jedi Council who went into hiding on
the planet deoa and obiwan Kenobi
mastered to Anakin Skywalker